Actors, artists, rockstars and writers have the ability to touch us on not only a personal scale but a global scale as well
We see these people on TV and on our bookshelves in the movie theaters and in the grocery stores, but what makes them so special
creativity
Creative people rule the world whether it's being media icons or designing the sleek new products. We see in use every day
we love creative people and we want to know all their secrets if
You want to produce music like Kanye or paint? Like Picasso here are 10 psychological tips from creative people
integrate art
Creative people are very vocal about the importance of exposing oneself to art
By integrating art into your life your brain starts to reflect on it
This trains you to look for meaning messages metaphor and other important information everywhere
Another benefit to looking at art is that you gain inspiration for your own art?
Although watching music videos might not seem beneficial it can give you the many ideas to work from to ask
questions
Creative people ask a lot of questions
What ifs and whys create a climate of curiosity?
It's through this curiosity that creative people are able to make connections gather information and develop opinions
Go ahead ask more questions and watch the creative ideas flow
3 work with your productivity
Most people get stuck in a routine, but is this the routine that's most effective for you?
creative people know when their most productive and they work with it not against themselves by
Embracing the schedules their bodies want to follow they're able to increase their productivity
You might even find you'll get more leisure time out of it, too
Did you know that how you get your energy can also affect your creativity?
Check out this video to find out why the most creative people tend to be both introverted and extroverted
4 express your ideas
Even if they seem silly at first
Creative people follow their ideas. They don't judge a piece until after it's complete or after it's been discussed
The more you express your ideas the easier you'll have access to them to
In the future ideas will come more naturally and she'll be quick on the draw for any brainstorming sessions at work five
Go on adventures
You miss out on life if you don't go on adventures and see the world
Creative people embrace the new they love different experiences and sensations
Because thrill-seeking allows them to explore and create possibilities for themselves and others
Being open is such an important factor
Creativity has to be free in order to sustain not boxed up and shut away
Six be an observer
It's important to also step back and observe the adventures you have
Observers get to take in everything and through that receptivity they develop unique and rich opinions
observe your surroundings in everyday life -
There's plenty of opportunities in the world only through observation. Do we find them though?
7 practice mindfulness
Mindfulness might sound like a buzzword nowadays
But it's actually really good for you
When you're being mindful of yourself in the world around you you can bring more positive energy and common to your life
Honesty becomes easier so does breaking old unwanted habits
Mindfulness also helps you achieve a greater attunement to yourself, which means you'll be able to play your strengths more eight
embrace risk
Risk is the driving force of a creative person and it gets great results
Often people who risk a lot fail a lot too. However, the more desensitized a person gets to failing the more they're willing to risk
This gives them the courage to explore their ideas and express the things they want to say
Creative people learned this long ago and embrace the risk equals reward scale 9
daydream
Just because you're not on task doesn't mean your brain is inactive by daydreaming
You're engaging different parts of your consciousness while letting your subconscious deal with the real problems
Daydreaming is also a great way to come up with creative ideas and situations that you might not otherwise give yourself permission to think about
It's like going on an adventure
but in your mind
create
When you get right down to it creative people create
They create experimental work successful work and a lot of failed work
But they keep going
they know that the only way to go farther in their work is to create more of that work and
That's a lesson. We all can learn the more we do the farther. We'll go. Who knows?
Maybe you'll be the next research scientist making big breakthroughs and saving lives
So what are you waiting for? Take the risk?
Which tips help you be the most creative?
Share your thoughts with us below
Also, don't forget to subscribe for more content from psych to go and check out our patreon
we started it because we want to grow into a bigger platform that reaches more people who were in need of help with your
contribution
You can receive our psi pendant t-shirt issues of our magazine and many more membership benefits
Your funding will help us produce quality script writing voiceovers and animation that makes our content both entertaining and educational
We want to make sure our community members get the best and only the best. Thanks for watching